oh
You ever have those days where you can't get out of bed?
You can't go to work even meeting people is terrifying your normal strategies of making yourself. Happy don't seem to work
I know the day's bad when no amount of Stevie wonder can pick me up
Sometimes I'm just feeling sad and unmotivated for no good reason
It doesn't happen very often, but when it does it comes to two main issues
For starters, how do I know that? I'm having a bad day as an introvert. I prefer being alone. I have a people limit
Sometimes I really need company, but when I'm at my worst not enough friends or positive thoughts can make me smile
I've learned is a difference between not wanting to leave fun and not being able to leave bed as an introvert
It's hard for me to distinguish bad days in meantime, but I know that during me time
I think about myself when it's a bad day
There's nothing just a void after going through the motions so many times I learned that
I need to be honest with my feelings. I can't ignore them until they go away
did something bother me that happened recently is a certain event affecting me is it hormonal have I reached a limit of people time if
All of the answers to these questions, and the others are no, I realize I've reached the no-man's land of I have no idea
Why I feel this bad, but I do or how I like to call it the Sonata
Meaning it helps normalize it and makes it feel less scary. It helps to feel like it's validated, so when this happens
I tell myself
I'm having a Sonata I've been through it before and I'll get through it again
But how do I deal with it calling a friend doesn't help for me
But it might for you different things help different people when I get like this my friends can boost my mood
But too much people time and I crash like I never left my bed to begin with nothing really cheers me up
I waste my day away doing nothing, but it's okay
I think that sometimes we need to have days where we feel bad for ourselves
We need to simmer in it and let the feelings run their course unless it interferes with your life
And the bad days become bad weeks or months you should be fine
I needed to accept that feeling bad is just as legitimate as anger or sadness
If you need to cry or punch something to get over something that happens the Sonata should be given the same treatment
I deal with it in my own way sometimes our brains in our hearts
don't work the way we tell them to as
A result we get stuck with feelings that we didn't ask for and had the potential to feel paralyzed. It sucks
I hate it and it throws off my schedule
It's an unnecessary weight that I need to carry it takes away from my life
But I need to allow myself to feel terrible sometimes
I admit that after I allow myself that it's easier to get through it I can get through, Senada